the White House says North Korea's
dictator will have to take quote
concrete verifiable actions before
meeting with President Trump last night
mr. Trump tweeted that the deal with
North Korea is very much in the making
adding it will be a very good one for
the world the date of the meeting is yet
to be determined for more we are joined
by Lisa Collins who's in our Washington
bureau Bureau she's a fellow with the
North Korea chair at the Center for
Strategic and International Studies Lisa
good morning thanks for having me
when President Trump made the
announcement Thursday about this meeting
was proposed meeting with North Korea's
Kim jong-un were you surprised I think
the news was certainly surprising the
fact that the North Korean leader had
actually invited president Trump to have
a summit and that president trim had
accepted that was surprising but beyond
just the shock value of the announcement
of the summit or potential summit I
think there are real questions about
first what will the two leaders discuss
or negotiate when they meet where will
the summit take place and then do the
two countries even agree on the same
concept of denuclearization or a freeze
of the North Korean nuclear weapons
program Lisa you mentioned the concept
of denuclearization is different perhaps
for Koreans that it is for those in the
United States can you elaborate more on
that so in the past when North Korea has
talked about complete denuclearization
of the Korean Peninsula they have they
have prefaced that by saying that it
wouldn't they would need the security of
their nation to be guaranteed and
usually what that means in practical
terms or what they have asked for before
is a removal of US troops from the
Korean Peninsula ultimately a
dissolution of the u.s. South Korea
alliance and then also the cancellation
or the stopping of u.s. South Korean
military exercises which happen each
spring and fall Lee so what do you think
the White House is looking for when when
they talk about the need for concrete
actions before this meeting can take
place well it's a little hard to tell
because the u.s. US officials and North
Korean officials haven't actually sat
down to talk about any of this yet at
the working level but I think what the
North Koreans probably are asking
for is something along the lines of
guaranteeing their security and then on
the United States side I think the US
would be asking for some guarantee that
the that the North Koreans are serious
about denuclearization which could be an
agreement to stop production of their
nuclear materials fissile and materials
to stop testing nuclear weapons and
ballistic missiles to stop producing
ballistic missiles so any number of
those things could potentially be and
asked on the United States part Lisa
this is a complicated diplomatic
maneuver that would seem to be greatly
compromised by the fact that so many
positions at the State Department are
unfilled there is no US ambassador to
South Korea there is no undersecretary
for for arms control and international
security how much of a problem is that I
definitely do think that is necessary to
have a US ambassador to South Korea
named as soon as possible we have a very
confident mark Napper the the current
person who's filling in for the
Ambassador is very confident but I think
we do need more people who are working
on the Korean issue there are lots of
people in the State Department who are
career diplomatic officials but I think
we we definitely need to pull together a
team that will be involved in the
negotiations with North Korea over a
potential u.s. North Korea summit all
right Lisa Collins thank you very much
for being with us this morning